jetzt blicken wir in die usa an stellen
uns die frage wie lebt jemand der nur
eines will töten wie lebt jemand der
menschen im supermarkt erschießt aus
rassistischem hass elton john hat dem
buffalo genau das getan zehn menschen
erschossen der rassist hatte nur
schwarze basieren und die schockierende
frage bleibt im raum wie konnte es zu
einer derartigen radikalisierung eines
davor eher unauffälligen teenagers
kommen der reporter herbert bauernebel
hat antworten in der heimatstadt des
killers gesucht
das massaker von buffalo amerika steht
weiter unter schock der kleine ort
kompletten liegt nahe der stadt
binghampton und circa auf dem halben weg
zwischen new york city und den tatort in
buffalo hier wohnte der killer peyton
gang drin es ist ein haus typisch für
amerikanische vorort idylle es gibt vier
schlafräume zwei badezimmer eine gesamte
wohnfläche von 290 quadratmeter der wert
geschätzte 260 1000 dollar das gebäude
liegt in einer weiten wiesenfläche die
generell familie galt in dem ort als
angesehen besonders seine mutter pamela
war in schulfragen sehr engagiert
aktives mitglied bei der
elternvereinigung gemeinsam mit ihrem
ehemann paul zog sie drei söhne groß
einer davon peyton dass er damals nach
drogen mit einer schule schießerei
kurzfristig in psychischer behandlung
landete wusste niemand der schock sitzt
tief in dieser winzigen gemeinde in der
hübschen hügellandschaft es ist fast
schwer vorstellbar wie in einer
derartigen idylle so viel böses
ausgehängt werden kann vor wenigen tagen
ist der junge mann hier völlig fanatisch
mit einem waffenarsenal
aufgebrochen zu diesem supermarkt wo er
dann das massaker angerichtet hat die
polizei hat alles untersucht hier eine
aussuchen durchgeführt hat festplatten
mitgenommen offensichtlich und computer
geräte man versucht natürlich
zusammenzuzimmern dieses puzzle
zusammenzufügen
wie es dazu kommen hatte können dass ein
junger mann ein 18 jähriger ein teenager
so viel hass in sich hat dass er eines
der schockierendsten verbrechen in der
jüngeren amerikanischen geschichte
begehen kann und
wir sprechen direkt mit herbert
bauernebel unserem us korrespondenten
der den heimatort des killers besucht
hat und herbert man muss sagen das ist
eine derartige idylle diese kleinstadt
das schwer vorstellbar ist wie dort ein
mensch so viel hass produzieren kann was
haben wir die nachbarn über den täter
berichtet ja es ist wirklich ein schock
wenn man das sieht dieses satte grün des
frühlings dieser hügellandschaften
sevelda und auch diese schönen häuser
dieses schönen ortschaften im zentrum
des bundesstaates new york das ist schon
wirklich sehr beachtlich und
gleichzeitig weiß man natürlich dass
in seinem zimmer oder vielleicht sogar
im keller hier etwas von statten gehen
von dem niemand etwas wusste oder
niemand etwas wissen wollte und hier
eben dieser hass ausgebrütet wurde er
sagt er selbst der der killer von
buffalo dass er sich selbst
radikalisiert hätte unter wenn man mit
den nachbarn dort spricht hört man doch
auch zwischen den zeilen dass der junge
mann doch etwas schüchtern gewesen wäre
ein bisschen eigenartig im sozialen
umgang sonst allerdings sagen die
nachbarn zumindest die wenigen die mit
einem sprechen dass es sich um eine ganz
normale familie dort gehandelt hätte das
alles sehr freundlich gewesen wären und
auch beten selbst ein ganz normaler
junger mann zu sein schien und das macht
die sache noch um einiges noch
gespenstischer eigentlich
was weiß man über die familie über die
geschwister des killers und er war ja
auch kurzzeitig in behandlung im
vergangenen jahr warum wurde dann nicht
schneller reagiert
ja wie gesagt er hat zwei brüder über
die ist nicht besonders viel bekannt es
ist auch nicht ganz klar ob er der
älteste sohn ist und natürlich sehr
hitzig diskutiert in den usa wird eben
dieser vorfall vom letzten juni als eben
peyton geht roth hat seine eigenen
schule von wo eben seine abschlussfeier
stattfinden hätte sollen dass er sieht
eben
einem schussattentat heimsuchen könnte
er wurde dann eben eingewiesen zu einer
kurzfristigen evaluierung und behandlung
in einem krankenhaus und dann allerdings
am nächsten tag wieder laufen gelassen
und das natürlich ist jetzt die große
frage in den usa warum wurde das nicht
vermerkt jemand der sich in
psychiatrischer anderen behandlungen
befunden hat wie kann es sein dass der
ganz legal eine waffe kaufen kann im
us-bundesstaat new york
zehn menschen mussten sterben herbert
und du hast mit einem menschen
gesprochen dass ganz knapp gelungen ist
seiner frau diesen unheil zu entkommen
dem tod zu entkommen wegzurennen es ist
auge in auge mit dem amokläufer und
diesen mit zu entkommen das hat dir
diese frau berichtet lasst uns gemeinsam
in diesen beitrag schon
es sind die dramatischen sekunden in
ihrem leben
prinz harrys denn viel rennt um ihr
leben und verliert dabei ihre tochter
aus den augen 72 stunden später
berichtet sie uns am tatort von den
minuten die sie ein leben lang nicht
vergessen wird
ich packte meine tochter und rannte los
und dachte sie ist hinter mir
dann wurde ich von einer dame umgerannt
die auch mit ihrer tochter floh
ich schaffe es aufzustehen und zum
ausgang zu laufen dort viel mehr dann
plötzlich auf dass meine tochter
verschwunden war
die schüsse das töten die angst um die
eigene tochter es sind quälend lange
minuten der ungewissheit für die mutter
da wüsste ich war geschockt und total
verzweifelt ich habe jeden gefragt wo
ist mein baby wo ist meine tochter hat
sie irgend jemand gesehen zurückgehen
konnte ich auf keinen fall denn wenn ich
zurück gelaufen wäre hätte er mich
erschießen können und wenn sie bereits
erschossen worden war hätten ihre kinder
nicht nur mutter los sondern auch ohne
großmutter aufwachsen müssen und ich
wusste das darf nicht sein
es dauert eine weile und 30 minuten bis
sie die gewissheit hat ihre geliebte
tochter lebt
auf der anderen seite des gebäudes hörte
ich rufe sie ist hier siehst hier und
wir müssen uns fast auf dem boden und
rannten in einander vor erleichterung
weil sie gedacht hatte dass ich tot sei
und umgekehrt
ihre rettung in der gegend in der sie
wohnen sind schießereien wie diese keine
seltenheit also bereitete sie all ihre
kinder darauf vor
wir haben in unserer gegend schon häufig
schüsse gehört ich erklärte meinen
kindern immer verhaltet euch so ruhig
und unsichtbar wie möglich wenn so etwas
passiert und sie tat genau das
doch nicht jeder an dem tag hat solches
glück
sie sah wir unseren ehemaligen manager
erschoss und wie eine andere person zu
boden fiel sie ist traumatisiert
zehn menschen verlieren ihr leben wegen
rassenwahns
fragrance selbst möchte keinen weiteren
gedanken mehr an den täter verschwenden
ich denke an meine familie ich denke an
die gemeinde an ihn denke ich nicht ich
versuche mich auf einem höheren niveau
zu begeben als diese
sie wird bald in ihren alten job
zurückkehren
aber eins ist klar es wird nie wieder
wie vorher sein
ein berührender bericht von herbert
bauernebel unseres korrespondenten
herbert vielen herzlichen dank dir